just better be the right place because
if this isn't the right place someone's
about to be real confused
Barry hey I knew it I knew that was you
I knew if you would have weird me yeah a
good couple tries to get here up this is
my friend Cisco Oh friend is a loose
term we work together hi
Cisco I have to say it this is a nice
University you got here thank you
okay do you remember last year when I
helped you out and you promised to do
the same for me what are we up against
hey youtubers it's Charlie so we're
finally here crossover time has started
so there's gonna be an explanation for
what's going on what you need to do in
just a shout out I'm bringing the flash
ring giveaway back so I'll explain that
in a second but watch this quick behind
the scenes that I'll explain everything
so 308 invasion is that what set this
out I hope to uh since it starts out
like a normal episode and then suddenly
is that a meteor oh yes that is a meteor
and yes it is heading for downtown but
as Barry runs to see how he can stop
anybody from getting hurt what he
realizes that this really isn't Meerut
meteor at all it's an alien ship aliens
hey alien aliens our little green men he
sees for the first time that aliens do
exist and they are the creepiest things
you've ever seen and they go by the name
dominators that is not the name of a
species that comes in peace no no it's
very aggressive Barry thinks it's the
best idea is to create the superhero
team he enlists all of his super friends
that is so cute you guys are just gonna
get together and go fight some aliens
have you lost your mind on top of that
if they're gonna fight aliens he wants
to use an alien to train against them so
he goes to earth 38 and gets Cara zor-el
known as Supergirl okay do you remember
last year when I helped you out and you
promise to do the same for me what are
we up against so this is gonna be great
and the flash rings are back in stock
just explain the giveaway it's just like
normal all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on this
video but make sure that you turn alerts
on click that little bell so that you
get all the videos just because
YouTube's been weird and people have
been missing out on stuff now what the
hell is going on with his giant
crossover so last night on Supergirl it
was largely a self-contained episode
just for Supergirl stuff that was
happening not crossover stuff but every
once in a while during like really weird
moments portals would open like Cisco
was trying to find his way to her earth
they still haven't technically given her
earth a designation like they jokingly
call it earth CBS so like Cisco's been
trying to find it so every once in a
while when something really crazy
happens a portal opens like she's
getting her ass handed to her by cyborg
superman he says no one will be able to
help you all of a sudden a portal opens
like and you think that Barry is going
to jump through and kick his ass but he
doesn't so they get to the end of the
episode which is kind of like an
Eradicator type story I'll explain that
in a second but then Barry and Cisco are
finally able to open a portal inside her
apartment so even I was a little
surprised with how light the crossover
was but they said the reason they did it
this way is because supergirls earth is
still in a different universe they
haven't got to the point where they want
to combine it with Barry's like they're
not going to do like some giant universe
changing thing yet maybe for next year's
crossover now that they've introduced
the idea of aliens and earth 1 which is
where flash and arrows earth is so
tonight on the flash episode 8 is the
first real night of the big crossover
like it's all dominator storyline from
here on out so tonight on the flash
episode 8 then tomorrow on arrow on
their hundredth episode then on legends
of tomorrow legends is the last night of
the crossover if for some reason you
haven't been watching all the shows it's
totally ok like the stories are very
self-contained to this big crossover so
if you have no idea what's up with
Prometheus on arrow or you don't know
what the legends have been doing this
season you'll be totally fine just watch
the episodes I'll be doing like full
episode videos for the flash arrow and
legends of tomorrow with a couple bonus
videos in between there'll be a couple
extra crossover videos this week just
because what they're doing is so big
which makes the video schedule just a
little bit weird but I'll explain that
at the end of the video but what's
happening is the dominators are invading
earth one just in Barry and Oliver
universe Supergirl is in a different
universe but they did say after this big
crossover event the dominators would
come back in the future on Supergirl
so I'm guessing that's dominators from a
different universe so last night on
Supergirl it was largely a
self-contained episode just for
Supergirl stuff that was happening not
crossover stuff that's probably because
just Supergirl Montel the characters
themselves like Martian Manhunter our
galactic characters so it's easier for
them to do galactic villains but on the
flash and arrow most of the villains
come from Earth so even though they're
going to defeat the dominators somehow
they're still going to continue to be a
big character just like the flash
defeats the
they always come back just like Oliver
was able to fight off Deathstroke he
always comes back
speaking of which arrow 100th episode
there are a lot of you that have been
watching arrow for the last season or to
their hundredth episode is going to be
crazy make sure you watch that if you
have not been watching arrow but as we
go along I'll be doing Easter Egg videos
for the flash later tonight then arrow
legends of tomorrow bonus videos
throughout just four special things that
are like way above and beyond but next
week what's going to happen is that
they'll all get their mid-season finale
they'll go back to their own storylines
so like the flash will go back to
fighting dr. alchemy and sabot R arrow
will go back to fighting Prometheus
they're actually going to be doing some
pretty crazy stuff on arrow in the
mid-season finale in episode 10 when
they come back in January most of you
have probably been watching the flash
but you might not have been watching
arrow so there's supposed to be some
huge twist with Black Canary coming back
on arrow in the back half of the season
so make sure you watch I mean obviously
I'll be doing videos for it but make
sure you watch to see how they pull it
off because they've already said that
they're not going to be using a lot of
the twists that they used in the past
for bringing back dead characters so
like the arrow 100th episode Katie
Cassidy is going to be in that but the
twist is a little bit different it's
going to be like that batman the
animated series episode perchance to
dream so it's going to feel very
different because it's going to be a
dreamlike state so supposedly that's not
how they're bringing back Laurel even
though she will be back for that episode
and I do expect Tommy to be in that too
they pretty much brought every big
character that's ever been on arrow so
that means like Deathstroke is going to
be kicking a lot of ass so they'll still
be a bunch of Dominator stuff happening
but there'll be a lot of special arrow
100th episode stuff happening so don't
worry if you guys have big questions
about what's going on how it's going to
work just let me know in the comments
I'll be dropping my flash video after
the episode airs tonight it's going to
be so crazy I can't even believe that
they attempted to crossover for shows it
is some Rick and Morty level [ __ ] that's
going on here
and yes I will be doing a Rick and Morty
season 3 video really soon
why don't we say Wednesday before I post
my arrow 100th episode video so I'll
explain all that Rick and Morty stuff
tomorrow that's like
completely separate show if you don't
watch it yet everybody else in the
comments that does watch it will let you
know exactly why it's so awesome so this
giant DC four-way crossover is a
logistical nightmare but it gives me so
much hope for what they're gonna try
next year because they always try to top
each other they try to do it with the
villains that they bring onto the shows
they also try to do it with the way they
tell stories so when this is all over we
can theorize about how they can top this
I have a couple pretty easy ideas and
they include Mongol and war world
so get hype let me know what are you
guys most excited about I mean obviously
they're going to be doing so much crazy
team-up stuff and this is all based on
the invasion comic book storyline so
I'll be pointing out all those comic
book Easter eggs when I post those
Easter Egg videos but see you guys
tonight is going to be awesome well you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here for my Game of Thrones Season 7
teaser trailer finally got some official
footage and you can click here for my
flash playlist
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight